margaret neil
is the adams distinguished professor
emeritus of management at stanford
university's graduate school of business
her teaching and research focuses on
negotiation and decision making
collaborations the allocation of burdens
and benefits
learning in groups and teams group
decision making
and diversity in a nutshell basically
everything
she is a professional of everything in
addition professor neil has conducted
executive seminars and management
development programs around the world
for those of us that or for those of you
that joined us a couple weeks ago we
have some
technical difficulties we're so happy
that you are back with us today maggie
thank you so much for being here please
take it away it's always a pleasure to
have you with us
thank you robin and let me add my
appreciation for those of you who
have shown up uh a second time i
appreciate the fact that
sometimes the technology is simply not
going to cooperate let's hope it does
today
so let's talk about negotiation and one
of the biggest hurdles especially for
women
is that most of us look at negotiation
as a battle
and that battle is characterized by i'm
going to try to get stuff from you
that you don't want me to have and i'm
going to try to keep you from getting my
stuff
and if that's how you think about
negotiation you're already
in an uphill climb and the reason is
because this negative frame this
perspective of battle of negotiation
creates a filter through which you
evaluate your counterparts behavior
and because they are the other they are
the enemy they are the people who are
keeping you from getting what you want
you're going to interpret their behavior
in the most malevolent way possible
and in addition if you think about
having this battle mentality
it really encourages you to think about
who's going to win and who's going to
lose
and that win-lose perspective creates
a pressure for you to try to win and
sometimes
winning becomes more important than what
it is
you have won now there are clearly
negotiations that are adversarial
but for you and for me most of our
opportunities for negotiation
take place with folks with whom we have
or have the potential for a relationship
so what that means is if you think of
negotiation as a fight
you have to pick and choose your
negotiations based upon
which counterparts you're willing to
pick a fight with
and so what i'm going to suggest is that
there's a better way
first we need to rethink the definition
to move beyond the simple notion of
negotiation
as a fight to negotiation is a process
where two or more parties decide what
each is willing to give
and hopes to get in their interaction
and the next
clause is so important and through a
process of mutual
influence and persuasion there is no
command and control in negotiation
i can't force you to say yes all that i
can do is present proposals
where from your perspective if you're in
your interest
to say yes and we agree on a common
course of action
now this definition is very broad and
can incorporate
all sorts of interactions some of which
are incredibly adversarial
but some of which are situations where
you might not even think of them
as the possibility for a negotiation
like
for example consider an ex a common
experience for me
is my research meetings when i call my
doctoral students to a research meeting
the content of that meeting is about how
to create
a better research project and how to
move that project forward
but the context of that meeting is which
of my scarce resources will i contribute
to this particular endeavor
and what do i hope to get and there
my students they are doing exactly the
same thing
so every meeting in which you wish to
have influence
is an opportunity for negotiation but
you're not going to take advantage of
those opportunities
if what you think of negotiation is a
fight
you're going to have to pick and choose
again who you're willing to fight with
and simply that's just not something we
want to have
as a characteristic that people think
about when they think about us
so what i want you to do is i also want
you to rethink your whole perspective
about negotiation
move from framing your negotiation as a
battle
to negotiation as collaborative problem
solving
now before you get to moving much faster
than i am
and say oh i already know what that is
that's that win-win
perspective in negotiation you know
where everybody gets together at the end
of negotiation there's a big group of
kumbaya there's you know unicorns and
balloons and rainbows everywhere no
when i talk about collaborative problem
solving there are three criteria that
you need to meet
number one to basically
be in a situation where i as the
protagonist negotiator and better off
better off than my status quo better off
than my alternatives
better off than had i not negotiated now
while that may seem like a low bar
i challenge you i suspect that all of
you
as i have been in negotiation situations
where at the moment before you said yes
you knew you should walk away
but you said yes anyway you took an
outcome that made you worse off
so first we need to sort of focus on
what makes us better off
number two because there is no command
and control in negotiation
i need to understand my counterparts
because my counterparts have to
voluntarily walk this path of agreement
with
me so i need to understand them i need
to understand their motives
their their preferences their interests
and their problems because i've got to
be able to craft a proposal
that from their perspective at least
keeps them whole and perhaps makes them
better off
otherwise there's no reason for them to
ever
say yes and third and most
importantly when i craft that proposal
i am going to frame that proposal as a
solution
to a problem that my counterpart has
you see too often we get caught up in a
negotiation thinking about what's in it
for me
but because you need to be so aware that
negotiation is an interdependent process
my counterpart has to come with me on
this journey
so i'm going to frame my proposals as a
solution to a problem that they have
now this turns out to be actually a
challenge
why because you've got to be creative in
how you frame
and characterize your proposals you've
got to plan and prepare
you've got to understand your
counterpart the good news is
that folks tell you their problems all
the time and i encourage you
to listen carefully to their problems
and see how creatively you can frame a
solution
to those problems in a proposal that
makes you better off
as well now once you do this
everything can become negotiable because
you're no longer
having to pick and choose your
negotiations based upon who you're
willing to fight with
but you've got to be careful because now
when so many things become open to
negotiation
you have to be clear about what you're
trying to achieve
in each of these negotiations and let me
be really clear here
the goal of a negotiation is not to get
an agreement getting a yes
is not the goal of a negotiation
and what i want to highlight is what
researchers have talked about as the
allure of agreement
and so i've got this graph here on this
figure
and i want you to look at the relative
positions of the orange bar
of the orange line and the blue line in
the blue line
this is the uh results of of negotiators
and and subjects in the experiment who
were asked to make a choice between two
options
option a and option b this is the
percentage of folks who chose option a
option a was a disadvantageous option
not so much so that nobody chose it
but you see that depending upon the
particular experiment
somewhere between a low of four percent
to a high of about 35 percent
chose option a the experimenters then
simply changed the label that they used
in the choice instead of saying option a
versus option b it was the agreement
option
versus the no deal option same
choice and look at the orange line
how many more people thought hey this
was a good idea
so that space between the orange and the
blue line is really the bias that we
have to agreement
so when folks say to you if you can just
make this concession
we have an agreement they have reduced
the friction
for you to make a concession and of
course you've done the same thing
but i wanted to sort of quantify how
powerful that allure of agreement is
because what you really want from your
negotiation
is a good deal and so now you need to
think well
okay if what i want is a good deal then
how do i know what a good deal is and
what i want to suggest to you is
there are at a minimum three
components that you need control of
before you
begin a negotiation the first is
what are your alternatives if this deal
does not
result in an agreement what we're asking
here is what happens to you in the case
of an
impasse we're looking here at
alternatives
how good or poor are your alternatives
to this particular negotiation
there has been an enormous amount of
research to look at the impact
of alternatives on negotiator
performance and while there's lots of
details in that research
the main finding is strong and
consistent
she who has the better alternatives on
average walks away with more in the
negotiation
why because the better your alternatives
the easier it is for you to walk away
or to convince your counterpart that you
will walk away
if you don't want to because if i have a
really good alternative
you're going to have to pay a premium to
me to stay in this negotiation because
otherwise
i can just invoke my alternative so
that's the good news
here's the bad news most of us when we
think about our alternative
we kind of characterize it as let's say
my alternative is here
if i just exceed this i am doing well
what you have just done by that
concoctation
is you have just anchored yourself to
your alternative
it now becomes a standard for
acceptability
acceptable outcomes what i want to
suggest to you
is that a better way is to think about
your alternative
as a safety net so imagine yourself a
trapeze artist
and you are performing before a large
audience
and somewhere in your act something
happens and you end up in the safety net
this is not an acceptable performance
you're not happy with what happened
but you're in the safety net
and because the situation was resulted
in your being in the safety net
you're really glad it's there that's how
i want you to think about your
alternatives
it's not a standard that determines
what's acceptable or good
enough what it is is it is a
mechanism that protects you from the
downside from the fall
now your alternatives are outside the
negotiation but they affect
the negotiation process itself and they
do so
through their impact on your reservation
point
your bottom line your point of
indifference between a yes and a no
this is arguably the most strategic
piece of information
that you have in your negotiation that
is what is the point
at which your negotiation goes from an
outcome
that you could say yes to to an outcome
that you
must say no to in fact
if you are negotiating and you're at
your bottom line
another term for your reservation point
if you're at your bottom line
you should be so indifferent that you're
willing to flip a coin
and if the coin comes up heads you walk
away
and if it comes up tails you say yes
that's how indifferent you should be
your reservation point is a bright line
standard that you do not violate
how easy that is to say how hard that is
to do
and just what i want to suggest to you
is that what successful negotiators do
is they are clear in understanding
that regardless of how much they want a
yes
that if the deal violates their
reservation price
they simply say no
now if all you think about is your
alternative
your safety net or your reservation
point
the worst possible deal you could say
yes to you will systematically
underperform in your negotiations
and this is sort of writ large for women
and the reason for that is because women
have lower expectations on average at
least the empirical research suggests
that
so what you need to do is literally
leverage
up your expectations about what is
possible and that is through setting
an aspiration an optimistic assessment
of what you could achieve in this
negotiation
and if you can leverage up your
expectations
you may not you may not realize you may
not achieve your aspiration
but setting an aspiration will result on
average and you're walking away with
more in the negotiation
and because women historically have had
lower expectations
this is so critical setting
an optimistic assessment if this
negotiation went well
for me what could i achieve
now you can have those three components
but you still got to decide to negotiate
and i want to sort of highlight the
importance
of why women need to engage in
negotiations
and the one of the most powerful ways i
can do that is to
to describe a study that was done
with 184 managers from a very large
organization
they were divided into two groups they
were both male and female managers
and they were told that they had a
specific money amount of money to
allocate
to their subordinates who were equally
skilled and responsible
both male and female subordinates and so
there were two conditions in the first
condition they were told simply
we need we have this fixed pool of
resources please allocate
these raises to these equally
responsible and skilled
employees and in that condition there
was no difference
in the allocation of raises to men or
women
however in the second condition
the managers were told that once they
had allocated this
fixed pool of money that the
employees could come back and ask for an
explanation
and perhaps negotiate with them about
the raise they were given
and in that condition the
managers both male and female managers
gave the male employees two and a half
times the raises they gave the female
employees
in this case women were at a
disadvantage before they even started
negotiating or even had the opportunity
to negotiate
why this difference well
when we're when negotiators went when
the managers were asked
why they did what they did they said
look
when we give women raises they're not
going to complain
but men will so men will come into our
office but not all men
and not given every race so if we give
them a high enough raise a lot of folks
won't come into our offices so what
they'll do is
they were very instrumental taking money
from jane
and giving it to bill to keep bill out
of their office
because they knew jane wouldn't
negotiate
so why don't you negotiate
and oftentimes we need to think that
we don't even think about it as an
option there are so many situations
where we can we we potentially have the
opportunity to negotiate
but because we have a motivated
misperception
that you can't negotiate here
and i want to dispel that perception
there are so many situations
where people think you can't negotiate
and i just want to suggest that you have
to ask
in fact one of the things that i do with
my students at stanford
is in the first assignment they have to
go out
and negotiate a fixed price item
and they need to bring back proof and
the item that they have purchased that
item for
less than the fixed price they have to
go to nordstrom's
or grocery stores or dry cleaners
they have to go to places where you
don't normally negotiate
and bring back proof in the item that
you can
and by the way when i first give this
assignment about 15 percent think
they'll be successful
but about 85 percent are successful
at the end of the assignment so what i
want you to think about
is the opportunity to negotiate in
situations
where most folks would say you can't
negotiate here
and i would challenge you try
but there's a big other group of
situations where people
know other people negotiate let's say
for example you're being made a job
offer
or you're being given offered a
promotion and you say to yourself
i know other people negotiate
but i'm concerned about the adversarial
nature of negotiation i don't want
to get a reputation for being greedy or
demanding or not nice
so here's what i'm going to do i'm going
to take that job or i'm going to take
that promotion
and i'm going to do really good work
and then when my employer sees my really
good work
then i'll get what i deserve have both
thoughts ever run through your mind
and if they have how'd it work out for
you
well i can tell you that for me i'm
pretty sure my dean
likes me and when i do good stuff for
the graduate school of business at
stanford
i'm pretty sure he's pleased that i'm a
faculty member
but i can also assure you that when i do
really good stuff for the school
he doesn't think i'm wondering for
paying her enough
just doesn't cross his mind
so let's talk about the choice
to negotiate and the way i want to do
this is i want to highlight a piece of
research you may have heard about
linda babcock is the co-author of a book
called women don't ask
negotiation in the gender divide and
what led her to write that book
was her stint as an associate dean
at carnegie mellon university she was a
negotiation researcher and as associate
dean
she did what we all did uh we all do and
that is we send out
exit interviews to the mbas as they
leave and so one of the questions was
what's your starting salary
in your new position and what she found
was the starting salaries of men were
7.6
higher than those of the women
graduating
same year same degree now
there's a lot of reasons why this could
happen but it turns out that because
linda was a negotiation researcher
she asked a second set of questions and
she said was
when you got your offer did you attempt
to negotiate the terms of your
employment contract
and what she found was that only seven
percent of the women
while over half of the men attempted to
negotiate
for more money she also found something
she said how successful were you and she
found
no difference by gender so everybody who
negotiated on
average got about seven and a half
percent increase in their salaries
so at this point
i think it's interesting for us to talk
about the cost of not negotiating
and the way i want to do that is i want
to do that
through a thought experiment so i want
you to engage with me in this thought
experiment so
suppose at age 30 two equally qualified
applicants
chris and frazier get job offers for a
hundred thousand dollars a year
okay and they're working for the same
company
now chris negotiates now let's say chris
gets an increase of 7.6
so chris starts out at 176.
frasier accepts the hundred thousand
dollars
and now we're going to make two heroic
assumptions number one
they stay at the same company for the
next 35 years so we can see what happens
and number two the company treats chris
and frazier identically
they give chris and frazier the same
five percent raises
annually okay now chris retires at age
65.
so the question i need to ask you is how
much longer
do you think that chris that frazier
will have to work
until frazier makes as much money as
chris did when chris retired at 65.
and i just want you to think so all
we're saying is how much did that
decision
35 years ago cost frazier
in terms of additional years of
work and i guess i'm wondering
would you be surprised if the answer
were seven years
so in order for frasier to make as much
money as chris did
in 35 years frazier has to work
42 years hmm
so maybe that negotiation thing may be
important to pay attention to
but it gets worse because this was a
very conservative
estimate of the difference because you
know
what happens if you think about this
over the course of those 35 years while
their salary started off very close 107
and 100
000 over those 35 years the difference
between their salaries now
at the 35th year is more than a hundred
thousand dollars
a year different so how does the company
how does the company interpret that
salary difference
well they're probably going to say chris
is more important
we pay chris moore nobody's going to say
oh you remember 35 years ago
chris negotiated and frazier didn't
nobody's even around who still believes
and remembers that
right they may not even be alive so
let's say
that chris gets half a percent five and
a half percent over those 35 years while
frazier gets five percent
you wouldn't even notice that difference
on a year basis
but over 35 years how much longer will
frayser have to work now
18 years longer and i'm going to do one
more and then we'll stop
what if chris
got six percent as a raise every year
and fraser got
five percent now how many more years
47. frasier can't live long enough
because french has got to be over 100
before
frazier will earn an equivalent amount
of money
so the cost of not successfully
negotiating one starting salary could be
in addition
seven to 47 years of work yes
this is an extreme and hyperbolic
statement i want this to be embedded in
your minds
and if you do the math and you realize i
still don't want to negotiate given the
cost
then i hope you like your job because
you'll be working there for a lot longer
for a lot less
so let's talk a little bit more about
women why women don't ask
and there is a significant amount of
research that gives us some insight
when we negotiate a single issue like
salary
women are less likely to negotiate than
men but
it's for a good reason it turns out
that evaluators penalize female
candidates
for asking for a raise in ways they
don't penalize
male counterparts particularly male
evaluators penalize females for asking
for more
while not penalizing their male
counterparts
now there's a little bit of good news in
kind of a weird way
female evaluators penalize both male and
female candidates for asking for a raise
so
at least the playing field's level it's
still not good
why do they do that it's the perception
of not being nice and being too
demanding
that explains the backlash and so
part of what i also want to highlight is
it's not just the penal
the penalties that women experience it's
a combination of the penalties with the
low expectations
that they will actually achieve their
outcome and so you bring those two
together
and it's clear why women are less
are more hesitant to negotiate
we also have done some research recently
um to try to understand this a little
better and it's a little bit different
because we
part of what we're trying to figure out
is uh is it the case that women are too
nice when they negotiate that is
they aren't pushing hard enough or are
they getting a backlash
when they try to negotiate and so we
have two competing hypothesis
women aren't sufficiently asserted
that's the tameness account
are that women are fine in terms of
assertiveness
but they get backlash so we
we basically collected data for five
years
got 2500 individuals who were in uh
executive education programs from around
the world
and what we found was a very interesting
effect
what we found first was that there was
no difference in negotiation
performance by gender so the notion of
women not asking
wasn't really a possibility here because
everybody in this data set were all
in a situation where they knew they were
going to negotiate so this
difference between the propensity of
women not to ask
and for men to ask is going to be
mitigated here
what we looked at but we found a very
interesting finding and that was
when women had good alternatives so in
this situation
negotiators could have good alternatives
or poor alternatives
and of course that means they were
facing counterparts both male and female
who had good or poor alternatives
and what we found was is that when
female negotiators had
good alternatives and were facing
counterparts
with good alternatives that is two
equally powerful players
women were six times more likely to
reach an impasse with their counterpart
male or female it were a male with a
good alternative
and this finding strongly supports
the backlash account because what we
find is and we can sort of see it in
this graph
it basically we have a strong
alternative
and males actually um got a whole lot
more
and when you see the dark box here this
is a female with a strong
alternative uh and you see that in fact
they got significantly less and that was
whether we included the impasses
or we exclude the impasses the effect
remains the same
so one of the challenges is is that when
women act assertively in negotiation
there is pushback from their male and
female counterparts
and so what i want to suggest to you is
we need to think
differently about how we negotiate
what i would like the world to be is
that there would be a level playing
field and i wouldn't have to
basically say to you to women you have
to behave differently in order to be
successful
but in this case there continues to be
evidence that the playing field is not
level
and so women have to behave differently
in order to get more of what they want
so what has to happen
women have to act differently
they have to ask differently
and it turns out and this research has
been going on for quite a long time
that women are going to be much more
effective if they pair their
ask with a communal concern
for the other now what do i mean by
communal concern
well it turns out that's that's
collaborative problem solving approach
how can my ask help you
achieve the goals that you want to
achieve
you see this is so important because
if women simply ask for themselves they
get pushback
and so if what we can do is we can couch
our ask in a solution
that helps my counterpart and make it
clear how that solution
does solve problems of my counterpart
we change the nature of the conversation
no longer is this a battle now
we're simply trying to find solutions to
problems
and so what i want to highlight is
the power of the ask if you don't ask
for what you want
how will others know what it is you want
and the one of the ways that i want to
highlight this
is that i want to give you a really sort
of
bad news good news kind of perspective
and so it turns out that when women ask
for themselves
they typically get less than their male
counterparts
you know and this is equating everything
same vedas same person you know but just
a male versus a female right
same verb same words right
women will get pushed back where men
don't when they're asking for themselves
but
when asking for others
women are more successful negotiators
than their male counterparts in fact
when asking for
others women outperform
men 14 to 22 percent
this is a huge
difference because what this says
is and this is a very important data
point because what this says
is it's not that women can't negotiate
it's that
when we do negotiate and sort of ask
for assertively what we want
we find ourselves in a backlash
situation
but when we ask for others there's no
backlash
you can't you know i don't get accused
of being greedy or demanding
or not nice when i'm negotiating for my
organization or for my team
where i get those accusations is when i
negotiate for myself
so this is why the problem solving
perspective is so important
remember that first criteria i need to
be
better off in my status quo better off
than my alternatives
better often had i not negotiated but i
couple that
aspiration with
trying to propose or framing a proposal
as a solution to a problem that my
counterpart has
and all of a sudden the conversation is
different
i want to highlight the power of the ask
because if you don't ask for what you
want now you may have to be clever in
how you do that
but if you don't ask for what you want
who will
and so what i want to do is i want to
say a couple of things in closing before
we open this up
for questions and one of the biggest
challenges
that i think women face when they're
negotiating actually not which is when
they're negotiating
but in the world is the competence
versus likability paradox
so it turns out that men can be
competent
and likable but
women are often faced with the choice
whether to appear competent or to appear
likeable
that is competent women are often
perceived as not
likable and likable women
are not perceived as competent
so the question that i would like to
have you consider and i think this is
not something that can be answered
in the moment it has to be something
that is answered over time
and again and again how much are you
willing to pay
to potentially be perceived as nice and
to deploy
and to avoid the discomfort of asking
and why i want to highlight this notion
of potentially be perceived as nice
because as you are more successful as
you move up in the organization
in your organization as you take on
leadership
there are going to be people who do not
like what you do
and we all want to be liked
and so there is a tendency if we have to
choose
sometimes we choose likability over
confidence
but what i want to suggest to you is
that you may want to think
about disentangling the situations
where you are competent and where
likability is really important and so
what i want to suggest if likability is
important
and by the way it is important i want
people to like me
but i also know that sometimes i have to
make tough decisions in my role
as a faculty member in my role as an
administrator
in my role as a mentor that makes people
unhappy and they find that i'm not
particularly likable in the moment
well what i've learned over time
is i can come home after work and my
husband
will say to me something like well how
was your day and i'll tell him and then
he'll go on about his business
but i have three dogs and when i come
home from work whether i've been gone on
a trip and i've been gone for a week
or i have just gone to the grocery store
and i've been gone for an
hour they're like oh my god you're back
it's so wonderful we thought we thought
you were gone forever
and our life was so sad and lonely
and dark without you we're so glad
you're here
you see if you really want to be liked i
have a solution
get a dog or better yet get a rescue
and save two lives because they will
love you unconditionally
and that's where you can get your
likability needs met
at work i'm not saying don't be likable
don't be personable
but don't sacrifice confidence for
likability
so we need to be strategic in how you
ask
i'm encouraging you to embrace that
collaborative
problem-solving perspective i cannot
overstate how important that is
you see you can think about it from my
perspective
i do research in negotiation i teach
negotiation i write books in negotiation
and so my colleagues and i've been an
associate dean when my colleagues
i get into a room with my colleagues
they're like oh you're negotiating and
they start putting on that battle armor
getting ready for a fight and i'm like
no
no no no i might negotiate with people
out there but with you
we're gonna problem solve it diffuses
the situation
it changes the conversation i want to
encourage you to embrace
the notion that negotiation is
collaborative problem
solving because what you're trying to do
is trying to influence people to move in
directions
that otherwise they wouldn't go
and part of the way to do that is to be
able to leverage
the opportunity to help them
at least be whole are perhaps made
better off
so another closing thought
especially for women for whom do you
negotiate
because you're going to do a much better
job when there is somebody
else for whom you are negotiating
whether it's your team
or your organization or
perhaps you're negotiating for all those
women who come after you
so those 184 managers don't take away
from
jane and give to bill because they know
jane will just
take it jane won't complain jane won't
try to change the situation
so if you want to know more
here a couple of things i want to
suggest as opportunities
for extending your knowledge about
negotiation
influence and the collaborative
problem-solving approach
the first is i want to highlight linda
babcock and sarah last year's more
recent book
ask for it how women can use the power
of negotiation to get what they really
want
this is a book that is directed towards
wise practitioners
so read this book get this book it's
really very useful
i'd also encourage you to perhaps
explore work by robert cialdini
on influence uh he has a 2009 book which
is
an amazing uh discussion of
influence and how to be more influential
in situations
he also has two recent books one's
called pre-suasion
which was published in 2016 which
focuses on
uh setting up the situation so that your
influence is more powerful
and also less a book he wrote
a little bit earlier called the small
big these are small influence attempts
interventions that can have big impact
i also strongly encourage you to read an
amazing book that was written by
oh me uh in 2015 published
there getting more of what you want how
the secrets of economics and psychology
can help you negotiate anything
in business and in life it makes a great
holiday present so
feel free um also uh please
take the opportunity if you wish to
explore my website
getting more of what you want dot com uh
there are video clips
there are articles there their blog
posts
um you know there's just all sorts of
stuff that's there i kind of throw up
whatever i
do i kind of throw up there you can see
some other examples of lectures i've
given
uh and you can actually see my co-author
thomas leasy has at least one short
video
there so you can see what he looks like
and with that
i think we are open for questions
maggie thank you so much i really i've
heard that
um i've heard that webinar a few times
from you and i
just really enjoy it and every time i
take something else away for it thank
you so much
we have many questions
i i would like to start with something
that i think that probably a lot of us
think about so we made the decision
we've mustered up our courage we're
gonna go in we're gonna negotiate
question is how can we gain insight
into the pay and benefit ranges for our
role
so that we know when we're going in
we're doing ourselves a favor by
starting the negotiation
from a competitive place
so you know the world has made this a
whole lot easier than it used to be
because we've had all sorts of of
resources
on the internet which can give us
information
about like glassdoor as an example
where they attempt to ask people and
it's it's not verified so you need to
take these things with grains of salt
but people give their their um
job category and the the salaries that
they have so you can begin to get an
idea um and there's lots of these type
types of websites that are out there so
that's one way
uh but you know what what i find much
more useful is something that i've been
doing
even before we had these kinds of
websites and that is
um i have a group i'm actually
use my network and so when i am
and thinking about going in for us for a
negotiation around my compensation
package
i'm going to gather information from my
friends and
it turns out early on um you can imagine
i got my phd in 1982 and there were very
few women
uh business school professors at the
time and so a group of us
got together there were about uh about
seven of us at the time
who were all coming out the same year
getting our phds and we we were meeting
at a national meeting and we said you
know what
you know we're a very small minority
here in
business schools and so we're concerned
that we're probably not being paid
equitably with our counterpart our male
counterparts
and so what we'd like to do is we'd like
to form a posse
and the posse's task is that over time
we're going to share
our information about our salaries about
our compensation packages
anything that we can do to help each
other uh and that's the
that's the pack we made because of
course it's uncomfortable sharing
information about salary and
compensation packages why
because number one you don't want to
feel bad oh i'm the one making the worst
amount of money here
or you also don't want to make other
people feel bad in case you're being
paid more but it might make you feel a
little good
right so what we did was we made it pact
and um that pack was made in 1982
and here we are in 2020 and i actually
got an email about six months ago from
one of the members of
the of the posse who said i'm going up
for some compensation conversations
where are where is everybody and we all
respond
so my my suggestion to you actually is
use the internet to get that kind of
information
but also use your network and
also you might not you might use it
expand your network and you could
certainly ask people who have jobs that
are similar to the one that you're
thinking about or the one that you
have and say i'm considering you know
asking for a raise in this amount would
that be
reasonable that way you're not asking
them how much do you make
but you're saying you know do you think
this is a am i under pricing over
pricing or
right at the right plot place for me and
and i applaud your your idea that you
need to get information because you
absolutely do
uh you need to know what the what the
market is
and where you are in that market so um
there's a variety of sources internet
sources your network
and then maybe a posse that you may have
created um to help you
support your um your options in this
kind of context
excellent thank you i think that was a
really good way to frame it too so
if you're feeling like under the gun to
ask some specifics you could say
would i be out of line if i said this
that's a cool
that's a perfect give them an out
perfect
um i really liked this question i
thought probably a lot of us can take
something away from this
can you provide some tangible examples
of positioning your
ask communally for example
in an offer negotiation what are some
specific tactics we might be able to use
to negotiate in concert which with what
may also benefit
that individual recruiter hiring manager
or the business how can we
if we feel like we're negotiating
something very specific for us
how can we put in some communa
community to that so it turns out that
this this will lead you know
so we only had 45 minutes a lot of
things i didn't talk about
so i'm going to start talking about them
now and one of them is
that you shouldn't be negotiating a
single issue i am
i research and i are
powerful opponents of negotiating issue
by issue
or a single issue like salary because
you it's really hard as the questioner
here you know implies
to be communal when i'm saying hey i
want more money right
so what you need to think about is what
is the package remember
so you may have heard me over in the
last answer i said
talking about my compensation plan not
my salary
my compensation plan which is a
multi-issue
conversation so i would strongly
encourage you
as you go in for a conversation with
your
um with your employer uh about
[Music]
these kinds of compensation plans is to
have
multiple issues around things that you
think would be helpful
for you to do your job better and that's
the real mindset you want to have
what are the resources i need in order
to do my job better
this becomes communal because most
of our employers our superiors are
evaluated based upon how well their
subordinates work
right so we are now aligned i want to do
a good job you want me to do a good job
secondly you already know some of the
challenges that your managers face
and how can you with additional
resources
step up to the challenge of helping your
manager solve his or her problems
so remember what you're trying to do
here
is understand that they have to have
they have to be motivated to say yes to
you
right and so you know i can give you an
example of
what i did when i negotiated with
stanford
so there were a couple of things that
were um
that were actually unique to me right
why they were interested in hiring me
one of them was i had a lot of success
in in training and placing doctoral
students and another was i had a lot of
success in teaching
and it at stanford at the time in the
business school there was this very
strong
cultural norm that if you could do
research
then you couldn't be a very good teacher
and if you were a good teacher you
couldn't do research
and the dean was very motivated to break
that cultural norm
that good researchers could also be
excellent teachers
and excellent teachers could also be
good researchers right
he wanted to make that change so he was
looking for people who could fit that
mold
so i actually was successful in teaching
and research
and so what i provided when i
when i had my negotiation with him about
possibly coming to stanford was
here the package here's a package of
resources that i will need
in order to train doctoral students well
in order to do my research in order to
be able to teach effectively
and these are the things that are
challenges to stanford and
my skills and abilities can help
help you mitigate those challenges here
are the resources i need in order to do
that
right and so that is really important
because you see
there's a reason why they're trying to
hire you what are your skills and
abilities are there a reason why you're
promoting you
what opportunities can you use for that
at that point in time
to say okay here are the resources i
need maybe i need some
quiet time working from home to be able
to
you know i mean this is pre-coped right
time working from home
uh to be able to do some some thinking
in ways that i can't think at the office
because of all the interruptions so
maybe i need two days at home
i need to i need to tell commute all
sorts of things whatever
do i need a bigger marketing budget do i
need better technology do i need what do
i need do i need more lab space
right what do i need in order to do my
job better
excellent great putting it in a package
approach so giving them some things and
maybe some give on and
making it how can i help you help me
help you
yeah exactly um
here is a question that came in that i
think is applicable probably to a lot of
people
since we're in covid right now which is
been a challenging time for businesses
and institutions
if you have found yourself in a position
where
there's a hiring freeze so let's say
there's a hiring freezer there's a stop
on budget
or something like that or we're not
hiring any more people and
you want to negotiate your position
how can you kind of navigate that
well a hiring freeze isn't a promotion
freeze
so there's that number one maybe
you know be and and secondly um i have
you know in my decades of being an adult
and being in organizations i've been
through a number of
hiring freezes and let me just go back
to the first thing i
one of the first things i said which is
the importance of
asking i cannot tell you the number of
times i'm a rule follower
basically and it's taken me decades to
kind of un
un un connect myself with that rule
following propensity
uh you know i was told there was a
hiring free so
you know therefore i didn't even ask for
a promotion or a raise or anything and
yet colleagues of mine did
and they got them right so you know i
don't actually believe
much of what i hear anymore when they
say this is an absolute
absolute rule nobody gets x y or z and
the answer is well
maybe maybe not so let's see and if i
can ask in a way
that helps my counterparts figure out
that they're better off by saying yes
than saying no
then maybe there's an exception to be
made
so that's number one it's just to really
say okay
uh let's be clear here about what
what is and is not true and there are a
lot of things i mean i had a dean once
uh not my current dean by any means but
idea once who whenever
a faculty member went in to ask him for
something he always said no
because his his theory was if i say no
and you go away
it must not have been very important but
if i say no and you come back and say
well let's reconsider this and let me
tell you why this is
why no is the wrong answer he said
then i'm going to listen to you but just
because you asked for something doesn't
mean you're going to get it you actually
have to make a case for it
sure and i think that's a good point
about a rule followers and probably a
lot of our participants are i am that
only that they say well they said or
i talked to the ba you know so i that's
very helpful thank you
um we've had a few questions come in
about understanding how
race and age play into negotiation
is there a difference in how black
indigenous and people of color
should ask for an increase compared to
a white person so there's very little
research
um and so i so there has been a one or
two studies done
with african americans um
and the answer is that
as you would expect um the bar
is set higher for people for at least
african-americans i'm going to
generalize to people of people people of
color
um because uh you know there's just
there's there's so much um you know
systematic racism and discrimination
that and it's so and sometimes it's
overt and sometimes it's very subtle
so my suggestion again this is
you know if this is not um
a function of the studies the studies
just show the difference
and what we find is is that people are
much less willing
to grant raises to people of color
um and to women right so it's the same
kind of thing
my suggestion to you is that you it's
even more important
to embrace this collaborative
problem-solving approach and to really
move away from
thinking of negotiation as a fight go in
there
with an expectation that you're trying
to solve a problem for your counterpart
because think about this how difficult
is for
is it for people to think you're greedy
or demanding or not nice
when you're helping them solve their
problems so
change your mindset and again
uh you know we don't have a lot of
research but but the research that we do
have
doesn't does not bode well um it turns
out that basically white guys
have a benefit and the rest of us don't
right so lean hard into that communal
ask
yep um thank you for that
next question is this discrepancy or
focus on
niceness that you talked about
cross-cultural
the same across the u.s or across
different technical sectors for example
medical tech engineer finance do you
know any of um
any of that information so
um it turns out that um that
uh basically the role of women and i'm
and and i'm gonna put you should put all
this in quotes this is hyperbole but
it's true but it
has a lot of support in empirical
research the role of women is to make
people feel good
and you know whether we're
in california or new york or in
you know uh iowa uh
the role of women is to make people feel
good and when you ask them for more
money you're not making them feel good
and so you get pushback
and so part of the reason part of the
reason that i have
i have settled on this collaborative
problem-solving approach is because
we are often women are often called upon
to try to solve problems we've been
doing that a lot
for all most of our lives and so it is a
natural
form of engagement and so as such
it allows us to be more effective given
the social situation in which we of
which we are apart
it is not a whole lot different uh
across uh across the across the
continents
um women's role is particularly
oftentimes characterized as
uh being more in terms of caretaking and
collaboration rather than
quote agentic communal versus agentic
right and so my my suggestion to you is
embrace it uh until the world changes
until we're in a place where we can
change the world and we do change it
then realize that that communal
perspective
you'll be able to be more effective in
getting what you want
if you leverage that perspective
absolutely thank you maggie that was all
the time we have for today just to round
back
i did have a number of questions about
books resources
or links that maggie would recommend for
us to dig deeper into this process
you can see her information up here on
her last slide
she also have we have linked her website
in your dashboard as well so you can go
there directly
and she's given us a number of insights
and books
that we can all um look to for more
information also maggie has a
negotiation course within the sia
certificate
this was yes this was 45 minutes a day
with a 15-minute question and answer but
her
course is 10 to 12 hours depending on
how speedy you are so you might want to
check that out
and we have also linked that in the
dashboard as well
thank you everyone today for joining us
we are so happy to have you thank you
for all your questions and your
participation
uh thanks for showing up maggie thanks
so much for showing up it was a pleasure
to have you today
and we will see everyone again soon
thanks everybody thank you robin take
care stay safe
be healthy stay safe everybody bye
you